[Musique]
le 15 décembre
si nous sommes bien arrivés autour des
5000 contamination par jour et environ
2500 à 3000 personnes en réanimation
nous pourrons alors franchir un nouveau
cap des critères loin d'être rempli plus
de onze mille cas ont été recensés ces
dernières 24 heures en attendant le
vaccin là parce que voilà il va arriver
donc voilà il faut tenir encore un tout
petit peu et c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression que là c'est la dernière la
dernière colline à franchir et bien même
quand il fait froid on peut faire noël
un petit peu dehors on peut faire un
apéritif dehors les barbecues avec des
chamallows c'est super sympa c'est noël
non mais c'est dire on a le droit aussi
de voir les choses de façon un peu
positive et et d'inventer enfin je veux
dire ça laisse des souvenirs que vous
avez aussi la théorie d'axel kahn que je
trouve aussi l'excellente qui consiste à
dire qu'on fera noël quand il fera beau
un peu plus tard et noël en avril ou en
mai ça peut être très sympa tu en fait
déjà on a tous des problèmes dans nos
vies en plus des problèmes on nous créer
d'autres problèmes
après ça il va y avoir quoi il faut
manger son gain quoi en fait on s'est
rendu compte que le bio ça va pas et en
fait c'est il faut manger son caca au
hockey
[Musique]
c'est pas possible c'est trop film home
y'a pas un sourcil qui bouge quand tu es
content pas content je suis très content
et un plafond j'ai pas très démonstratif
à savoir moi je sais très bien où
quelqu'un je sai baba gardes avaient
ouvert la bonne âme et la concacaf route
qui pille on doit aussi je savais que ça
allait marcher
non mais ça le rapport mais c'est bien
est ce que c'est ce qui fait rire rend
pas mal ça marche à tous les coups d'un
oui j'ai décidé de laisser les enfants
sans couche en espérant qu'ils ne
montrent pas trop sur mon canapé un pas
d'accident et
hélas ça ne joue pas maintien maintenant
mattia ma fille là tout à coup la
chaleur l'a déjà déjà pour commencer je
vais te dire un truc si chaud tellement
que tu me mets un soda
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a tous scolaires mines et minéraux
chante jul alors forcément s'attaquer à
moi j'aime bien un tel classique et ben
vous êtes à peu près la seule pour leur
tort si on entend autant de musiques
urbaines
c'est pas hasard c'est charles trenet
aujourd'hui pas de la musique c'est
horrible
wemmel et l'europe flèche peu importe
jean-paul mortagne
vous connaissez pas parce que messi mais
le rapace et des aboiements
j'aimerais savoir si vous êtes partant
pour faire un album de rap faire des
feat avec donald trump
angela merkel même avec les ministres
etc
merci pour l'invitation à mon avis ça va
donner un résultat bizarre donc
réfléchissez bien avant de produire ce
truc
tant que je suis président à mon avis
c'est pas le meilleur truc que j'ai à
faire après moi je suis ouvert
didier le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas la même qualité musicale ni
mais la qualité de parole vous nous il
ya 40 ans aujourd'hui je maintiens et
autres ce sont des aboiements ces
maladies on va terminer par une leçon
pour pour l avoir vu les maîtres cleps
le nouveau rapport boris me prend pour
une bête ce n'est alors je suis pas né
de la dernière pluie
c'est pas moi quoi faire la grimace au
vieux sèches ont travaillé pour un
ministère de notre belle république tout
à fait tout à fait je travaille que l'on
ne va pas citer
merci merci beaucoup non mais c'est
difficile mais c'est pas les transports
visiblement il ya un boy's sais plus
thaçi irons-nous plus délicat on va dire
ça comme ça d'accord vous allez devoir
de retenue et discrétion oui et oui il
en faut et exactement il en faut très
peu comme un ton mi ser la défense un
tweet de guillaume meurice
guillaume meurice c'est quelqu'un qui se
dit humoriste france inter payez donc
par une parole manière par le pardon
alors voilà ce qu'il dit guillaume
meurice je sais pas s'il sera sanctionné
par sa direction laurence bloch
je sais pas mais je trouve ça tellement
absolument incroyable il dit bonne manif
à tous assez ab hashtag à sable et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ach agacé ab all cops are bâtard
on traite de l'actualité se débarrasser
son français sans arrêt en le
culpabilisant ou alors donner la parole
aux gens qui pleurnichent sans arrêt il
ya un ras-le-bol des planchas donc
laurence bloch qui est directrice de
france inter madame veil qui dirige
radio france
qu'est ce que vous allez faire rien rien
rien on a le droit de dire tous les
policiers sont des bâtards par quelqu'un
qui est payé par nos actionnaires dès
que je ne disais pas bien me dire ça
mais il ya un moment mais je trouve cela
veut dire on a on en a marre de payer
pour ça et tous les ans la marque payer
sur la loi devant est ce un scandale et
filtrer les salaires de monsieur maurice
peut-être qu'ils aient une conversation
avec albert et et votre fils qui vous
aurait échappé
qu'est ce que tu crois donc on s'aime
fabricants de pipes en gruyère depuis
déjà plus de 100 ans
pourquoi la bruyère parce que c'est un
bois qui ne brûlent pas qui résiste donc
à la chaleur on reste une industrie
artisanale parce que tout notre travail
est encore fait à la main ok ok super et
si on rigolait un doute parce que
pendant un reportage à julien qui m'a
avoué déjà un très beau sapin chez moi
j'étais vraiment reste opaque et par
l'info du l'un des bacs à merci julien à
toutes avérées très content pour vous
regarde regarde comment tailler une pipe
c'est magique le bois ah oui mais votre
avis c'est une belle matière égorgé et
segal vaudois il est bon de faire des
pipes je trouve et on a une petite
pensée pour le traducteur
à l'avenir je ne devrais plus organiser
de grandes par toulouse et jusqu'à ce
que la situation est terminée par ses
très bons aspects où le climat général
risque d'être des plus rudes une année
pas folichonne la continuation du coc
vide
ambiance de stress épidémie inondations
naufrage climat de révolte d'émeutes
last but not least des événements assez
dramatique pas très gai on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge
sur ce je vous souhaite une super nizami
bancaire